[Music]
now back home what does poverty mean in
this week's magazine liam mckenzie
writes that the term is overused and
co-opted by corporate brands
leo joins me now along with grace
blakely the commentator
leo grace thank you for coming on today
um leo you write in your piece uh how
the term poverty has taken on a new
meaning can you explain
well poverty is a genuine
problem in britain on a worrying scale
and it has been exacerbated by the
pandemic but i do think that uh that my
article shows how
poverty is both being
exaggerated uh by pressure groups the
incidence of poverty is being
exaggerated by new definitions used by
pressure groups in order to
grab headlines and
gain interest for their work and also by
big corporations that want to indulge in
a bit of virtue signaling by associating
themselves with a fight for social
justice and uh in both cases i don't
feel that there's a genuine concern for
addressing real poverty in britain which
of course exists as i say on a worrying
scale i live down and near margate and
of course i see poverty all the time
around me but i i think the incidence of
poverty is being exaggerated for
political lands and for corporate ends
and uh
there's so many examples of that one of
the most absurd is trans transport
poverty which the royal automobile club
the rac
define as
if you spend more than 10 of your income
on transport you are in
relative transport poverty which is
absurd of course because rich people did
by definition spend more of their income
on
transport whether it's on international
travel or gas guzzling cars or more on
petrol or more expensive cars or
first-class train travel and you
rendered the ridiculous situation that
those who defined in the biggest
transport property are the very richest
the people who own maybe
rolls royce and bentley's actually the
rolls-royce in the driveway is a badge
of poverty which shows how distorted
statistics can get when you go down this
road
grace do you think the term poverty can
be distorted when it's used by
corporations and the example leah just
gave is one where it's not so much
whether or not you can afford something
compared to your direct earnings says
the percentage of your earnings you're
having to spend on it which is a bit
further away than what i think people
would originally think
i mean i i have really actually
interestingly enough mixed feelings
about uh about this and i think my
feelings are really summed up by the
cartoon that's used at the top of leo's
piece which is on the one hand a kind of
indictment of consumerism and the
lengths to which brands will go to
convince us that we simply must have
things um often things that we don't
need in order to kind of be considered
uh legitimate human beings or to feel
good about ourselves but is on the other
hand a vilification of working class
people who do need those things and i
think there's something here about about
inequality and the impact that it has on
our perceptions and also the way that we
feel about ourselves and the way that we
kind of um
you know ascribe value to people and i
think on the one hand there's this issue
of perception it's you know very
difficult for people like us perhaps who
um aren't struggling on a daily basis to
buy the things that we need to imagine
what it would be like to live on you
know 257 pounds a month for example
which is the amount of universal credit
you get as a single person under 25. i
mean just the strain of having to
calculate firstly in the context of a
housing crisis after rent which is
something that's really non-negotiable
utilities food etc um you know just
being able to think can i have a coffee
for example or will that mean that i
won't be able to buy food for myself or
my kids which is genuinely an issue that
a lot of people face
um and i think on the other hand there's
this issue that in a highly unequal
society where you have people at the
very very top able to buy all these
things that brands are trying to
convince us that we need and others not
you have this sense that um you know
really in order to be considered a kind
of a human being of any dignity or worth
you have to be able to buy a pair of
trainers or buy this particular thing
that will make people look at you in a
certain way and certainly i think for
people who are in
jobs where perhaps they're either
ignored or treated basically with
contempt a lot of the time there is this
sense that maybe by buying things they
can become
you know worth something and all of
those issues are complicated and they're
linked to
the way that we conceive of ourselves
and the way that we conceive of each
other in a society that is marked by
quite extreme levels of inequality at
this point
leo's interesting there grace talking
about inequality uh and obviously
inequality and poverty are linked um but
when we're talking about uh being able
to purchase things from certain shops uh
particularly when we're looking at some
of these transport examples you could
say it's more inequality than poverty so
what do you define poverty as
well
i mean because that opens a huge debate
on
poverty absolute poverty which is uh
destitution and the struggling
for day-to-day
goods of life and relative poverty i
mean i always think that in in monaco
there must be people in relative poverty
or millionaires because they don't have
the the the yacht or billionaire status
so it can be terribly distorted and i
think that's one of the thrusts of my
article that uh how distorted the
figures can be and grace talked about
people struck struggling
but of course one of the uh points about
ever ever widening the definition of
poverty and talking about so many
endless new
categories of poverty like we there's
even talk of smartphone poverty if
people don't have a smartphone there per
holiday poverty uh bad poverty furniture
poverty
and uh if you widen the definition of
victimhood so much it becomes
meaningless i mean one one of the
statistics that i mentioned i think i
mentioned in my article was from a
charity that says
over 50 percent of londoners suffer from
hygiene poverty which means that they
can't afford basic hygiene products and
that just strikes me as an absurd
uh
[Music]
absurd assertion to make that more than
half of people in london one of the
richest cities in the world are actually
struggling to afford basic hygiene
products it doesn't make any sense
and then again you know this this speaks
to this question of inequality because
london is a very very wealthy city but
it is also one that is but are you
seriously saying very very high levels
of poverty sorry are you seriously
suggesting that more than half of people
in london can't afford basic hygiene
products
i wouldn't be surprised if more than
half of people in london have to think
very very seriously about the decisions
we all have to think seriously about
problems
it doesn't matter because it does i mean
you know we know from psychological
studies that just living in poverty puts
an immense amount of strain there is a
cognitive load associated with thinking
right i have this amount of income to
spend each week if i go to the end of
that that bit of income i will not be
able to buy certain things that i need
there's a um
an example that's used that's you know a
memorable way of describing what it's
like to live in poverty or on the edge
of poverty is do you live in dread of
getting a toothache or your car breaking
down because you just don't have the
amount of money that you would need at
disposable to be able to cover those
costs or
you know you would have to go to maybe
you know your bank or even to a kind of
payday loan company and pay extortion
amounts of interest just to be able to
cover those unexpected costs i would not
be surprised if there was a very very
large proportion of people in our
society living under those conditions
but more than half of londoners one of
the richest cities in the world it
doesn't really make sense and
i mean another claim made by a different
research group was that thousands of
people in the uk have little or nothing
to wear when they were talking about
clothing poverty and again that doesn't
really match reality i mean
the cost of clothing has come down by
more than half over the last 30 years we
actually live in an age where clothes
are incredibly cheap and to pretend that
most british people are living in death
or
thousands of british people are an
absolute destitution where they have
little or nothing to wear it actually
undermines the real fight against
poverty by creating disillusion and
cynicism by with these exaggerated
claims
i think there is there is a genuine
question here about kind of brand virtue
signaling um which you know and i i do
think that often brands will take
advantage of uh of these kinds of
campaigns to be able to kind of you know
whether it's accrue some level of um
you know respect amongst their their
consumers or just to kind of sell more
stuff that is definitely an issue i mean
when you talk about kind of transport
and clothing that's potentially a
question here but there's also something
about why campaigners often not just
brands feel the need to couch these
questions in these terms you know when
you go in the news no one wants to hear
about poverty or inequality no one wants
to hear about these big you know
basically features of the way that we
organize our economy and uh you know the
the solutions being quite transformative
um economic policies that would reduce
inequality they feel like very big
issues that would be very very difficult
to fix whereas if you're a brand
or you know a campaigner and you go on
the tv to talk about period poverty um
then it feels like something okay i can
understand what that is and also i might
be willing to
um you know donate or to to maybe
condone legislation that would deal with
this one specific area so there's a
question of of comms and communications
here that i certainly think is important
but it's also a question of you know the
challenges that we face in our society
as you mentioned poverty is so high this
feels so big
that it's hard to get your head around
it um and i think that actually requires
us not to talk less about poverty and
inequality but to speak more about those
issues and what we can really do at the
macro level to speak to the fact that
there are so many people in this country
who literally cannot afford at the end
of the week to make ends meet grace when
we're i suppose leaning to uh leo's
point about uh the way poverty is
bandied around by some corporations
these days i'm talking about smartphone
poverty holiday poverty do you think
that although uh talking about it more
widely is a good thing that does make it
harder to actually uh address the people
really in need those in absolute poverty
if we do overuse the term
i think certainly when it comes from
brands people have you know a legitimate
reason for being skeptical but i also
think often when we have these
discussions i mean i remember when we
saw this um with regards to food banks
there's a lot of discussion on twitter
as to oh seriously who could actually
not be able to afford food i've put
together this meal of like one egg and a
piece of toast and it cost me 15 p there
is this sense i think of a kind of
distinction between and this has always
been the case in the uk all the way back
to the poor laws the deserving and the
undeserving poor
um
it's it's the kind of thing you know
where you go along the street and you
see a homeless person and you think i'm
not gonna give them money because
they're just gonna spend it on drugs but
your perception of that changes when you
realize that um you know a third of
young people leaving social care become
homeless in the first two years after
leaving care and there are obviously the
these set of issues around mental health
physical health abuse poverty substance
abuse that mean that these people are
actually you know not undeserving poor
but actually living with a whole set of
very very difficult issues that make
their lives much much harder and that's
you know an extreme case but the point
does extend i think to poverty in
general which is that it is just hard to
be poor and it's particularly hard to be
poor in a consumeristic society like
ours that teaches people that if you can
afford a smartphone if you can afford a
new pair of trainers if you can afford a
range rover you are somewhat higher up
in the social hierarchy than someone who
can't
finally leo i mean we're talking about
and you make the argument that a lot of
this bending round of the term makes it
much harder to address real poverty so
what do you think the focus should be in
doing that
well i i think two things
should happen i think that we should be
much more rigorous about the definition
of poverty and not and not eat and
challenge pressure groups and
corporations that actually issue these
bogus statistics
like the claim that 43 of parents of
primary school children go without basic
hygiene products because they can't
afford it i mean about
four bars of soap from aldi i found cost
59p i mean is it seriously suggested
that
over 40 percent of
families in britain can't afford 59p for
four bars or so so i think we've got to
be far more rigorous about the
definition of poverty and also we should
concentrate resources
much more
which was what the last coalition
government was trying to do was
concentrate resources much more on real
need and if we fall for this argument
that half of londoners are in part in
hygiene poverty and that 80 of us in
transport poverty will get absolutely
nowhere you'll just have to spray money
around like
graffiti on such an epic scale that
you'll just have colossal waste and
you'll worsen dependency and you'll
heighten expectations i think what i'm
really calling for in this article is
much more rigor
much more skepticism and much more
challenge for the poverty campaigns who
make these wild claims
i think we just need to treat people
with a basic amount of respect and
dignity and
really try and put ourselves in the
shoes of someone who is living off a few
hundred pounds a month and imagine the
toll of being forced to make the choices
that they are forced to make and rather
actually i agree than saying oh let's
tackle this bit of poverty or that bit
of poverty and have a campaign and have
a brand sponsoring it let's actually say
not just spraying money around but think
about the very structure of our society
think about the problem of precarious
work of low wages of uh the immense
housing crisis that we have in this
country and actually say we need
coordinated top-down um and
expansive political action to tackle
these challenges that make so many
people's lives so hard in ways that most
of us can't is that a call for a massive
expansion in the welfare state
more than a call for expansion in the
welfare state it's a call for the kind
of democratization of ownership of
resources in our society we need to
rebuild our social housing system we
need to uh you know remove anti-union
legislation that makes it hard for
working people to be able to organize to
demand higher wages we need not just
kind of tinkering around the edges a
little bit more tax there a bit more
spending there we need a structural
transformation of the way our society
works
[Music]
you